we work for an institution like the
United Nations the institution itself is
at the center of some of the great human
events of our time and so to be able to
work with that institution means making
your contribution to forces far larger
than any than any individual and when
the butpeople crisis wasn't solved by
any one individual any one set of
individuals it was a gigantic effort
that involved a large number of
countries and their governments the
United Nations and the goodwill of a
large number of non-governmental
organizations and private individuals so
each of us played a part but that part
obviously engaged our consciences and
our human qualities and that that's what
made a big difference I I remember how
in Singapore when I was dealing with all
the refugees rescued at sea I could put
my head to the pillow at night knowing
that things are done during the day
persuasive attempts had made with
immigration officials my creative
creativity or ingenuity the rapidity and
effective action of my staff all of that
had actually made a difference to real
human beings lives I want to remember
stories after stories when I can tell
you one of a young Vietnamese family
they'd left their country in a tiny boat
with a cannibalized tractor engine or
something and sure enough the engine
contacts they began drifting aimlessly
on the South China Sea they ran out of
food they ran out of drinking water and
they were subsisting on rainwater and
hope their two small children with them
a baby and an infant so the parents
slits their fingers and made the babies
suck their blood in order to have enough
nourishment to survive now when this
family was rescued as it happens by an
American ship they were too weak to even
stand up they actually had bodily lifted
from the boat taken on board the ship
and when the ship docked the next day in
Singapore Harbor
my staff and I had to rush this family
to intensive care in a Singapore
hospital which meant begging and
pleading with the authorities to bend
all sorts of rules to allow this to
happen instantly because their lives
were in danger and then to see the same
family a few months later healthy
well-dressed ready to embark upon a new
life
in the u.s. quite honestly few jobs
provided the sort of satisfaction that
does see that as an individual
contribution no because I think the
contribution one was able to make would
not have been possible to make without
the United Nations the great strengths
of working for the UN was the UN as an
organization to which all governments
belonged you can say that you know
anybody can have refugees church groups
do it all the time compassionate
individuals do it all the time and sure
I use the word church groups
uncompassionate individuals in my camp
but only a UN official like myself could
talk to governments with the kind of
authority that a church group can't
because I could use the
intergovernmental clouds of the UN to
win asylum permission disembarkation
permission to get the various ministries
concerned together ships into the port
to allow refugees on board to allow them
temporary shelter in hospitals and in
camps and Singapore and then it was only
the governmental cloud that enabled me
to persuade immigration officers from a
dozen different countries to take people
who weren't otherwise qualified for
resettlement in those countries so the
UN gets the credit not any individual
for having been the mechanism through
which this great human drama can be
resolved but I would say they brought
individuals contribute in institutions
like the United Nations or the US
government or any other large body is
their intelligence their drive their
integrity their willingness to put in
all the long hours it takes I remember
handling peacekeeping in the former
Yugoslavia I had small kids at home when
I was often getting back home at
midnight because I didn't get a
particular cable of instruction or
guidance of information after Yugoslavia
before I left the office because of the
time difference if I did it the next
morning my colleagues in Yugoslavia
would lose an entire day and so there
was no question that you know you had to
devote yourself to putting frankly the
work ahead of anything else in order to
ensure it was done and that sort of
contribution is often lost sight of in
in when people study the work of large
institutions institutions are made up of
people
what those people do and how they do
them and we both skill and intelligence
and talent and conviction and conscience
they do them makes all the difference in
the world